Buonasera, allora questa sera parleremo di un'altra superstizione, non una superstizione medievale naturalmente, ma una superstizione nostra riguardo al Medioevo.
Ecco, nell'idea popolare, che poi condividiamo un po' tutti, di un Medioevo oscuro, di un Medioevo superstizioso, di un Medioevo arretrato rispetto allo splendore dell'antichità, ecco, in questa idea che più o meno tutti condividiamo, rientra anche questa immagine.
L'idea che a quel tempo fossero tutti convinti che la terra è piatta, tutti, non soltanto quelli che normalmente non si preoccupano di queste faccende, ma anche i dotti.
Fa parte della nostra immagine di Medioevo questa idea di dotti in realtà ignorantissimi e superstiziosi anche loro, convinti che la terra è piatta, o perlomeno che non osano dire nient'altro, che non osano insegnare niente di diverso, per paura di essere puniti dalla Chiesa.
Questa idea è così diffusa che probabilmente non devo dimostrarvi che è diffusa.
La condividiamo un po' tutti, o ci abbiamo creduto un po' tutti fino a un certo momento, che nel Medioevo si immaginassero la terra piatta.
Tuttavia cito un esempio che mi sembra probante.
Un'opera che è sicuramente indicativa della cultura popolare diffusa.
Un film che ci ricordiamo tutti dalla nostra infanzia.
La spada nella roccia, di Walt Disney.
Nel cartone animato La spada nella roccia, a un certo punto, vi ricordate, c'è il mago Merlino che insegna a Semola,
e il mago Merlino a un certo punto fa un viaggio nel futuro.
E torna dal futuro, se non sbaglio con gli occhiali da sole e i Bermuda,
e dice a Semola, nel futuro ci saranno delle cose straordinarie,
fra l'altro scopriranno che la terra è rotonda.
Quindi è chiaro che questi arretrati medievali non sapevano che la terra è rotonda.
In questa nostra immagine è centrale, naturalmente, la figura di Cristoforo Colombo.
Se non ci fosse Colombo non avremmo così in testa questa idea di dotti ignoranti che credono che la terra sia piatta.
Cristoforo Colombo è fondamentale perché Cristoforo Colombo, lo sappiamo tutti,
ha avuto grandi difficoltà per far approvare il suo progetto, per trovare i finanziamenti, per salpare con le tre caravelle.
E se Cristoforo Colombo ha avuto tante difficoltà, la versione che più o meno tutti abbiamo in mente,
è che gli altri non ci credevano che la terra è rotonda,
e quindi non ci credevano che lui, salpando da palo, sarebbe potuto arrivare dall'altra parte del mondo.
Abbiamo tutti in mente questa immagine epocale, vedremo poi quando è nata questa storia,
di Cristoforo Colombo davanti ai dotti di Salamanca.
Appunto questi dotti ignorantissimi che in tutti i modi cercano di boicottare Colombo,
perché non ci credono che la terra è rotonda.
E questo tema è oggi diffusissimo.
Per esempio, sono innumerevoli le vignette, le battute, le barzellette su Cristoforo Colombo e la terra piatta.
Se andate a vedere su internet si trovano.
C'è la vignetta delle caravelle che arrivano al limite del mondo ed effettivamente la terra è piatta.
E le caravelle cominciano a precipitare e tutti i marinai gridano a Colombo.
Ah, allora era rotonda, eh?
Ricorderei ancora un lavoro di un bravissimo fumettista nostro, Altan.
Qualche decennio fa Altan ha scritto un fumetto su Cristoforo Colombo.
E nel Cristoforo Colombo di Altan, memorabile devo dire, a un certo punto si vede Colombo che è in viaggio nell'oceano ormai da un bel pezzo
e non arriva alla terra, non si vede niente.
E c'è questa vignetta, c'è Colombo sulla tolda che tamburella nervosamente con le dita
e Mugugna è piatta, maledetta, è piatta.
Dunque, come voi sapete, almeno lo sa chi c'era ieri o l'altro ieri, qui il mio mestiere è di fare il guastafeste.
Cioè di dire, dopo aver fatto vedere questa bellissima immagine di questo mondo folle
che crede che la terra sia piatta, di dire
non è vero niente.
Questa volta è così facile che se dovessi soltanto parlarvi di quello finiremmo in dieci minuti.
Nel Medioevo lo sapevano benissimo che la terra è rotonda.
Come faccio a dirvelo?
Ecco, se qui avessimo potuto proiettare delle immagini ve lo facevo vedere subito
ma è un esperimento che potete fare quando tornate a casa, domani mattina magari.
Andate a cercare su un libro o su internet
una qualunque immagine di un imperatore medievale
una qualunque
che sia la famosa statuetta di bronzo di Carlo Magno a cavallo
che sia una miniatura che raffigura il Barbarossa per esempio
o che sia un bassorilievo che rappresenta un imperatore bizantino
tutti sempre hanno in mano
nella sinistra di solito
tutti sempre hanno in mano il simbolo del loro potere sul mondo
un globo
a volte sormontato dalla croce
per indicare che il mondo sarà dominato dalla religione cristiana
ogni imperatore medievale è raffigurato con un globo in mano
per indicare il suo potere sul mondo
che come tutti sanno è un globo
ma siccome non possiamo proiettare delle immagini
e adesso qualcuno di voi magari può dirsi
ma io non me le ricordo queste immagini
raccontiamo anche qualcos'altro
i dotti del medioevo
si preoccupavano di come è fatto il mondo
e di come è fatto l'universo
leggevano dei trattati
e scrivevano dei trattati
sulla forma della terra
è certo che lo facevano
e adesso
spero che non sia una parte troppo noiosa
ma dato che devo dimostrare la cosa che vi ho detto
cioè che loro lo sapevano benissimo
che la terra è rotonda
citiamo qualche fonte
nel settimo secolo c'è un monaco in Inghilterra
che si chiama Beda
tenete conto che il settimo secolo
è nel pieno di quella fase del medioevo
che gli inglesi chiamano tuttora
dark ages
i secoli oscuri
il settimo secolo è un momento in cui
c'è veramente un basso livello culturale
scrivono poco
non ci hanno lasciato grandi risultati
è il momento nel complesso di maggior declino culturale del medioevo
nel settimo secolo
in quel posto sperduto che è l'Inghilterra
il monaco Beda
scrive una serie di opere
uno potrebbe dirmi
sì Beda scriveva
ma chi lo sapeva?
no, le opere di Beda
sono state copiate
hanno circolato
esistono moltissimi manoscritti
delle opere di Beda
stavano in tutte le biblioteche
Beda scrive
traduco dal latino
noi chiamiamo la terra
globo
non perché non ci siano delle irregolarità
di montagne, pianure
ma perché se consideriamo tutto l'insieme
la circonferenza della terra
rappresenta un globo perfetto
Beda si preoccupa della forma della terra
anche in un'altra occasione
scrive un trattato sul calcolo del calendario
sui tempi, sui giorni, sugli anni
parentesi
perché si occupano di questa roba?
ma perché la chiesa medievale
è interessatissima al calcolo del calendario
bisogna calcolare quando è la Pasqua
tutto l'anno
come dire
religioso dipende da dei calcoli
bisogna saperle queste cose
Beda scrive un manuale su come si calcola la Pasqua
e a un certo punto gli viene da dire
vi sarete accorti che d'estate i giorni sono più lunghi
e d'inverno i giorni sono più corti
perché
dice Beda
il motivo per cui i giorni
non sono tutti uguali
è la rotondità della terra
rotunditas
non per niente
nelle pagine della Bibbia
e anche nella nostra lingua comune
si parla dell'orbe terrestre
infatti
è sempre Beda che sto citando
settimo secolo
nel pieno dei secoli bui
infatti è un'orbe
posta al centro dell'universo
e vabbè qui dobbiamo scusarli
non è che abbiamo capito tutto
per loro come per Tolomeo nell'antichità
la terra era al centro dell'universo
ma è un'orbe
dice Beda
rotonda
quando Beda dice che la terra è rotonda
si accorge
che c'è qualcosa che non va
non basta dire che è rotonda
perché rotonda
è una parola ambigua
e qui visto che prima ho citato
il fumetto di Altan
mi permetterete di fare
un'altra piccola divagazione
nel mondo della cultura pop
del fumetto
c'è o c'era ai miei tempi
un fumetto ambientato nel medioevo
un fumetto comico
una strip comica
che si chiamava
il mago di Id
the wither of Id
c'era questo regno medievale
con un piccolo re cattivissimo
in una striscia di questo fumetto
a un certo punto
ci sono i dotti
del regno
che discutono
sulla forma della terra
e si dicono
è rotonda
no non è vero
è piatta
sotto po'
è un fumetto
degli anni sessanta
per chiarire
che non ci perdiamo
sottopongono al re
la questione
e il re
esce a pensare
poi torna
ha in mano qualcosa
che non si vede
e il re
dice
ho deciso
la terra è rotonda
ed è anche piatta
e tutti dicono
scusa com'è possibile
e il re dice
io la chiamo
la teoria della pizza
e fa vedere
una pizza
che ovviamente
è rotonda
ed è anche piatta
ho fatto questa divagazione
per dire
che quando Beda
nel settimo secolo
dice
la terra è rotonda
si accorge
che non basta
perché
e allora Beda dice
la pizza non la conoscevano
nell'Inghilterra
del settimo secolo
Beda dice
la terra è rotonda
non nel senso
di uno scudo
ma piuttosto
di una palla
rotonda
allo stesso modo
da tutti i lati
dopo Beda
nel corso del medioevo
continuano a uscire
trattati che parlano
dell'universo
dell'astronomia
e della forma
della terra
e si vede
che gli autori
di questi trattati
continuano a avere
qualche problemino
col linguaggio
perché appunto
dire che la terra è rotonda
rischia
di non bastare
e quindi
c'è tutto uno sforzo
di far capire
anche a quelli
magari non tanto colti
a cui si cercano
di spiegare queste cose
e allora è meglio
spiegarle con delle immagini
piuttosto che con dei teoremi
vi cito qualche brano
da vari trattati medievali
sulla forma della terra
la terra
è rotonda
come una palla
questo l'aveva detto
anche Beda
se non ci fossero
ostacoli
potremmo camminare
tutto intorno
al mondo
come una mosca
su una mela
dopodiché ci sono anche
autori che dicono
senti risolviamolo
questo problema
del linguaggio
rotonda non va bene
però c'è una parola
che non può
suscitare dubbi
sfera
il più importante
trattato
medievale
sulla forma
della terra
è stato scritto
da un monaco
inglese
nel 200
un monaco
che si chiama
Giovanni
di Sacrobosco
e questo trattato
sulla forma
della terra
si intitola
in latino
De Sfera
trattato
sulla sfera
tenete conto
lo dico anche qui
come nel caso di Beda
perché uno potrebbe dire
sì lui l'ha scritto
ma chi lo sapeva
il trattato
di Sacrobosco
era diffusissimo
era il libro
di testo
standard
nelle università
medievali
appena hanno inventato
la stampa
hanno stampato
il De Sfera
di Sacrobosco
è uno dei primissimi
libri stampati
già nel 1471
quando la stampa
l'avevano appena inventata
nel giro di 30 anni
escono 25 edizioni
a stampa
del trattato
di Sacrobosco
La Sfera
in altre parole
quando Colombo
discute con i dottori
di Salamanca
ma sarà poi vero
che Colombo
ha discusso
con i dottori di Salamanca
vedremo anche questo
quanto sia vero
ma in ogni caso
quando Colombo
va a chiedere
i finanziamenti
in tutte le biblioteche
d'Europa
c'è
a stampa
ormai
il trattato
del Sacrobosco
sulla terra
che si intitola
La Sfera
a questo punto
proviamo a fare
un passo indietro
mi hanno detto
che la prima sera
parlando dell'anno 1000
c'erano troppi flashback
che diventava difficile
seguire
scusatemi
facciamo lo stesso
un passo indietro
come mai
nel medioevo
almeno i dotti
sapevano benissimo
che la terra
è una sfera
ma perché
in realtà
lo sapevano già
gli antichi
e non è vero
che le conoscenze
degli antichi
si sono perdute
tante cose
sì
tanti dettagli
ma le cose
di sostanza
non potevano
perdersi
gli antichi
greci
sapevano
perfettamente
che la terra
era rotonda
e come facevano
a saperlo
ragioniamo un attimo
su questo
perché gli autori
medievali
sono gli eredi
di questi
e sanno
che la terra
è rotonda
perché fanno
gli stessi ragionamenti
che avevano fatto
tanti secoli prima
Aristotele
o Tolomeo
e sono ragionamenti
diciamolo
fra parentesi
che possiamo fare
anche noi
se mai ci venisse
il dubbio
perché oggi
è facile
uno dice
ho visto le foto
gli astronauti
dalla luna
hanno fatto le foto
la terra è rotonda
comodo
prima come si faceva
il fatto sconvolgente
è che prima
era facilissimo
capire che la terra
è una sfera
bastava mettersi
a ragionare
dice Aristotele
e questo in verità
non è un ragionamento
è piuttosto
osservazione
empirica
dice Aristotele
i navigatori
che vanno verso sud
ci dicono
che man mano
che vai verso sud
le costellazioni
in cielo
si spostano
salgono
e compaiono
nuove stelle
che prima
non si vedevano
e quando ti sei
molto allontanato
le costellazioni
sono tutte diverse
e Aristotele
dice
questo si può
spiegare
solo se la terra
è una sfera
perché se la terra
fosse piatta
muovendoti
le costellazioni
rimarrebbero
sempre quelle
magari non siete
del tutto convinti
Aristotele
dice anche un'altra cosa
che è veramente
conclusiva
anche perché
il viaggiatore
che è andato
fino al sud
è chi è che lo conosce
ma invece
ognuno da casa sua
può fare
questo semplicissimo
esperimento
la luna
l'ombra
della terra
si proietta
in certi momenti
sulla luna
quando noi
vediamo la luna
come una falce
è perché
c'è l'ombra
della terra
proiettata
sulla luna
l'ombra
della terra
proiettata
sulla luna
è sempre
circolare
c'è un solo
corpo
che proietta
un'ombra
che è sempre
circolare
qualunque sia
la posizione
perché la luna
sorge
e sale su
e poi tramonta
e l'ombra
della terra
è sempre
circolare
dice
Aristotele
non c'è niente
da fare
ragazzi
soltanto
una sfera
proietta
un'ombra
che è sempre
circolare
e poi
dopo Aristotele
viene
Ptolomeo
il più grande
geografo
dell'antichità
il più grande
geografo
anche se pensava
che la terra
fosse al centro
dell'universo
e per tanti
secoli
anche i cristiani
ci hanno creduto
il più grande
geografo
Ptolomeo
anche se
come vedremo
quando torneremo
a parlare
di Cristoforo
Colombo
parleremo
di quanto è
grande la terra
di quant'è
la circonferenza
della terra
Ptolomeo
su quello
ha fatto
confusione
ma non voglio
anticipare
Ptolomeo
però una cosa
la dice chiaramente
la terra
è rotonda
vuoi la prova
sei su una nave
che si avvicina
alla terraferma
sulla terraferma
ci sono delle montagne
prima vedi
la punta
delle montagne
poi man mano
che ti avvicini
le montagne
crescono
cominci a vedere
la base
e poi quando sei proprio vicino
vedi anche la spiaggia
dice Ptolomeo
questo può succedere
soltanto
se ammettiamo
che contrariamente
a quello che noi
crediamo
la superficie del mare
è leggermente
incurvata
altrimenti
non si spiegherebbe
questa cosa
bene
voi direte però
giustamente
va bene
gli antichi lo sapevano
ma
e anche i medievali
lo sapevano
l'abbiamo visto prima
ma siamo sicuri
che c'è un passaggio diretto
nessuno ha mai messo
in dubbio
queste cose
la Bibbia
cosa dice
e allora
fermiamoci su questo
perché
è verissimo
che i primi
cristiani
non tutti i dotti
del medioevo
che è durato
mille anni
ma i primi
cristiani
qualche problema
con questo fatto
della terra rotonda
ce l'hanno avuto
perché
se uno legge
la Bibbia
nella Bibbia
non viene fuori
che la terra rotonda
niente di chiaro
però nella Bibbia
ci sono
alcuni passi
che con tutta
la buona volontà
non quadrano
mica tanto
con l'idea
che la terra
sia una sfera
la Bibbia
teniamolo presente
è
un insieme
di opere
scritte
nell'arco
di parecchi secoli
nel mondo
ebraico
c'è tutta
dentro
la tradizione
storica
e sapienziale
di un piccolo
popolo
che non era
un popolo
dalla mentalità
scientifica
gli ebrei
non erano
i greci
gli ebrei
hanno una mentalità
allegorica
immaginaria
religiosa
e nei loro
libri
cioè nella Bibbia
non si preoccupano
di verità
scientifiche
parlano
un linguaggio
di un altro tipo
vi faccio qualche esempio
per capire
come mai
i primi cristiani
che sapevano
dalla scuola
che la terra
è rotonda
e quando leggono
la Bibbia
fanno un po'
fatica
a mettere
d'accordo
questa cosa
con quello
che hanno imparato
a scuola
perché nella Bibbia
per esempio
ogni tanto
ci sono dei passi
in cui
che Dio li perdoni
loro dicono
i quattro angoli
della terra
capite che
i quattro angoli
della terra
se uno lo prende
alla lettera
nell'Apocalisse
per esempio
Apocalisse 7
poi vidi
i quattro angeli
essi stavano
in piedi
ai quattro angoli
della terra
dice qualcuno
dei primi cristiani
vuol dire
che la terra
ha quattro angoli
cosa ci vengono a dire
i greci
che è una sfera
dove li ha
quattro angoli
la sfera
ma soprattutto
quello che si trova
di più
nella Bibbia
è l'immagine
del cielo
come una tenda
piantata
sulla terra
ricordiamoci
che gli ebrei
sono un popolo
di pastori
seminomade
per loro
la tenda
è un'immagine
estremamente familiare
salmo 104
hai disteso
il cielo
come una tenda
ancora
il profeta
Isaia
non avete capito
come è stato fondato
il mondo
Dio
siede
sulla cupola
che copre
la terra
di lassù
gli uomini
sembrano formiche
egli
distende
il cielo
come un velo
lo dispiega
come una tenda
dove abitare
allora
i primi cristiani
leggono questi testi
e dicono
beh
se la terra
ha quattro angoli
e il cielo
è come una tenda
e la terra
dove si pianta
la tenda
il piano
con i suoi quattro picchetti
ai quattro angoli
quindi
tra i primi cristiani
c'è qualcuno
che dice
vuol dire
che la terra
è piatta
e sopra
Dio
ha messo
il cielo
come una tenda
c'è perfino
un autore
nei primi secoli
del cristianesimo
si chiama
Cosma
Indico Pleuste
che in greco
scrive
su questa faccenda
e prova
perfino
a immaginare
fa anche
dei disegni
ci sono dei disegni
nei codici
delle sue opere
di questo cielo
teso
come una tenda
sopra una terra
che a questo punto
è piatta
sto parlando
dei primi cristiani
e non a caso
ho sempre insistito
i primi cristiani
tenete conto
di cosa hanno in testa
i primi cristiani
che vivono
di persecuzioni
hanno un atteggiamento
estremamente ostile
verso la civiltà
in cui vivono
i primi cristiani
sono convinti
che loro hanno dentro
una verità nuova
e che tutte le verità
di prima
è tutta spazzatura
da buttare via
i primi cristiani
sono convinti
che i filosofi greci
e gli scienziati greci
bruceranno all'inferno
e che tutte le cose
che loro credevano
sono false
come i loro falsi dei
e quindi
in quest'epoca
in cui il cristianesimo
è molto aggressivo
è molto sprezzante
verso tutta
la civiltà antica
appunto
si può trovare
qualche autore cristiano
che dice
la terra
è piatta
piccola parentesi
la perdonerete
al medievista
che vi sta parlando
questi pochissimi autori
che dicono
la terra è piatta
non sono autori medievali
sono autori
antichi
siamo ancora
nell'antichità
quando è la tarda antichità
quando il cristianesimo
sta venendo fuori
nella tarda antichità
qualche autore
che ha detto
l'ho letto nella Bibbia
la terra è piatta
c'è stato
se non che
non dura niente
perché nello stesso
mondo cristiano
questi che leggono
la Bibbia
alla lettera
e che si mettono
a discutere
sulla forma
della terra
a un certo punto
cominciano a risultare
imbarazzanti
tenete conto
che l'atteggiamento
dei cristiani
che si considerano
fuori dal mondo
ostili al mondo
ostili alla civiltà
in cui vivono
non dura mica
granché
basta che arrivi
Costantino
quando arriva
e finiscono
le persecuzioni
e l'impero
comincia a proteggere
i cristiani
e pian piano
tutta la società
romana
e greca
diventa cristiana
allora è finita
con questa storia
di contrapporsi
alla civiltà
classica
non è più tempo
di contrapposizioni
e allora
i più importanti
padri della chiesa
si preoccupano
perché questi cristiani
che vanno in giro
dicendo
la Bibbia
dice così
la terra è piatta
fanno una figura
grottesca
e i padri della chiesa
non hanno voglia
di dare l'impressione
che i cristiani
sono una manica
di ignoranti
analfabeti
potrà sembrare
un'espressione forte
ma è quello
che dicono loro
ve ne cito uno
l'ho già citato
nei giorni scorsi
perché è uno
dei pensatori
che hanno influenzato
più di tutti
il pensiero medievale
Sant'Agostino
fine del quarto
inizio del quinto secolo
Sant'Agostino
si pone proprio
questo problema
c'è qualche cristiano
che si mette
a discutere
con gli scienziati
e a dire
che la terra
non può essere rotonda
perché nella Bibbia
c'è scritto
che ha quattro angoli
e Sant'Agostino
dice
io la Bibbia
l'ho letta
non c'è niente
di preciso
sulla forma
della terra
è chiaro
che al Signore
non importa niente
della forma
della terra
lui l'ha creata
noi ci abitiamo
ma non è un problema
non è una verità
di fede
è ridicolo
che noi cristiani
ci mettiamo a discutere
di queste cose
dal punto di vista
della salvezza
la forma
della terra
non importa niente
a nessuno
dice Sant'Agostino
è una di quelle
tante cose
che dobbiamo
lasciare agli specialisti
e credere
agli specialisti
perché non c'è
un dogma
su questo
e Sant'Agostino
dice
questo ve lo cito
spesso
un pagano
si intende
della terra
e dei cieli
e del movimento
delle stelle
e questa conoscenza
la possiede
con certezza
perché viene
dalla ragione
e dall'esperienza
se permettetemi
fermo un attimo
su questa coppia
che rimarrà centrale
nel pensiero medievale
come fai tu
a sapere le cose
ci sono due modi
uno è l'esperienza
l'ho provato
ho toccato
con mano
l'altro
ancora meglio
perché è più nobile
non hai bisogno
di fare l'esperimento
ci arrivi
ragionando
l'altro modo
è quello che ti dice
la tua ragione
e dunque
continua Sant'Agostino
per uno
che non è credente
è offensivo
è spiacevole
sentire un cristiano
che dice stupidaggini
su queste cose
pretendendo
che quello
che dice
è basato
sulle sacre scritture
e Sant'Agostino
continua
dovremmo fare
tutto quello
che possiamo
per evitare
una situazione
così imbarazzante
ed evitare
che i non credenti
vedano solo
ignoranza
nei cristiani
e ridano
di noi
queste cose
Sant'Agostino
le scrive
in un libro
che si intitola
De Genesi
Ad Litteram
cioè
sull'interpretazione
letterale
della Genesi
in cui
Sant'Agostino
dice
non bisogna
interpretarla
alla lettera
alla Genesi
sono immagini
sono metafore
non ha nessun senso
interpretarla
alla lettera
e infatti
Agostino
nella stessa opera
quando parla
della terra
dice
la terra
è un globo
è ovvio
che è un globo
con una faccia
illuminata dal sole
e una faccia
in ombra
e Sant'Agostino
si preoccupa
anche di dire
quando la Bibbia
descrive
la tenda
si tratta
di una metafora
non dovete
prenderla
alla lettera
bene
allora
tutti sapevano
che la terra
era rotonda
beh
piano
perché c'è sempre
un problema
ci sono quelli
che si occupano
di queste cose
e che ci ragionano su
ci sono i dotti
e poi ci sono
anche gli altri
ci sono anche
gli ignoranti
che magari
mai nella loro vita
si sono preoccupati
di questi problemi
ma la prima volta
che senton dire
che la terra è rotonda
dicono
e come mai
io non la vedo mica
rotonda
la vedo piatta
gli ignoranti ci sono
e nel medioevo
è un tema
che viene fuori
spesso
proprio questo
noi dotti
lo sappiamo
che la terra è rotonda
certo
ogni tanto
con gli ignoranti
bisogna avere pazienza
bisogna spiegarglielo
nel dodicesimo secolo
esce un trattamento
è un trattato
di un teologo
che si chiama
Guglielmo di Consch
è un trattato
di filosofia
in cui c'è un capitolo
che si intitola
la forma della terra
questo teologo
del dodicesimo secolo
siamo 300 anni
prima di Cristoforo Colombo
si pone il problema
che noi dotti
lo sappiamo
che la terra è rotonda
ma come dobbiamo fare
per spiegarlo
agli ignoranti
e allora
immagina
un dialogo
è un dialogo
tra un filosofo
e un laico
tra un teologo
dotto
e uno
che non essendo
un uomo di chiesa
poveretto
non ha mai letto un libro
il laico
in questo
che fa la figura
dello scemo
a cui si spiegano
le cose come stanno
è il duca
di Normandia
perché evidentemente
non sono soltanto
i poveri
anche i duchi
hanno altro da fare
nella vita
che preoccuparsi
della forma della terra
e quindi
il teologo
chiacchiera
col duca
e il duca
gli dice
ho qualche dubbio
sulla forma
della terra
ma davvero
è rotonda
come dite voi
io non la vedo mica
e il teologo
gli risponde
certa gente
è come gli animali
perché si fida
delle sue sensazioni
piuttosto
che della ragione
diciamolo fra parentesi
nel medioevo
sono innamorati
della ragione
i dotti del medioevo
parlano continuamente
della ragione
hanno questa fiducia
inspiegabile
nell'uomo
sono convinti
che se l'uomo
si mette lì
e ragiona
può venire a capo
di tutto
e che quindi
basta ragionare
e dice il filosofo
appunto
certa gente
è come gli animali
non sa usare
la ragione
e quindi dice
che la terra
è piatta
perché quando va in giro
non si accorge
che è rotonda
e ho capito
che se vai in giro
non ti accorgi
che è rotonda
ma ragiona
dice il filosofo
dodicesimo secolo
e gli fa un ragionamento
se la terra
fosse piatta
sono un po' complicati
questi ragionamenti
queste dimostrazioni
ma vi infliggo
ancora anche questa
se la terra fosse piatta
immagina una città
posta nell'estremo oriente
appena sorge il sole
è già mezzogiorno
perché il sole
è già subito sopra
alla verticale
quindi in quella città
fra l'alba
e mezzogiorno
passerebbe un attimo
poi prima del tramonto
hai voglia
perché il sole
c'è ancora tutto
invece dice il filosofo
ci risulta
che l'intervallo
fra l'alba
e mezzogiorno
è uguale
in tutto il mondo
di conseguenza
la terra
non è piatta
il caso di questo
trattato
che vi ho menzionato
potrebbe farci pensare
che ci fosse
come dire
una spaccatura netta
i dotti
sanno
che è rotonda
tutti gli altri
sono convinti
che è piatta
non è proprio così
è che tutti gli altri
giustamente
come molti di noi
prima di stasera
non si erano mai preoccupati
di questo problema
e non ci pensano tanto
ma c'è nel medioevo
un chiaro sforzo
di
come dicevano loro
volgarizzare
cioè rendere comprensibili
anche agli ignoranti
le cose più importanti
nel medioevo
c'è un libro
famosissimo
è un libro di viaggi
immaginari
non è come il libro di Marco Polo
che magari abbellisce
anzi abbellisce molto
però insomma
lui ci è andato in Cina
il libro di cui vi sto per parlare
si chiamano
i viaggi del cavaliere Mandeville
sono proprio inventati
il cavaliere Mandeville
non è mai esistito
però descrive
questo libro
un'infinità di viaggi
nel mondo
e racconta
com'è fatto il mondo
è un libro
tanto per cambiare
di enorme successo
nel corso del medioevo
nel 3-400
viene tradotto
in tutte le lingue
a costo di annoiarvi
vi darò anche la cifra
delle edizioni a stampa
viene stampato
appena inventano la stampa
entro l'anno 1500
fanno 35 edizioni a stampa
di questo libro
parentesi
vedete come comoda
questa cosa
uno vuole sapere
quali libri
erano più popolari
erano più letti
vai a contare
le edizioni a stampa
e così hai la prova
provata
che un libro
lo leggevano tutti
nei viaggi di Mandeville
si racconta
che i navigatori
quando vanno in giro
per i mari
e vanno verso sud
a un certo punto
arrivano in dei posti
dove non si vede più
la stella polare
è un ragionamento
che abbiamo già fatto
lo faceva già Aristotele
ma qui lo ritroviamo
in un libro medievale
e soprattutto
in un libro
scritto per il grande pubblico
un best seller
se volete
tant'è vero
che io adesso
ve lo cito
direttamente
nella traduzione
italiana
medievale
dice l'autore
appunto
i navigatori
che vanno a sud
dopo un po'
non vedono più
la stella polare
per la quale
ragione
si può comprendere
che il mondo
si è
di rotonda forma
e questo appare
notate bene
per esperienza
e per sottile
indagazione
e ancora sempre
la coppia
di Sant'Agostino
mille anni prima
ci sono due modi
per sapere le cose
esperienza
far l'esperimento
e sottile
indagazione
ci penso
su
e ci arrivo
e continua
Mandeville
che se
si trova
a passaggio
da nave
ed è gente
che volessero
andare
cercando il mondo
se li potrebbe
andare
con navigli
intorno
al mondo
siamo
150 anni
prima
di Cristoforo
Colombo
più o meno
naturalmente
Mandeville
specialmente
nelle versioni
tradotte
nelle lingue
volgari
come dire
usa un linguaggio
un po' grossolano
comprensibile
a tutti
lui vede
la terra rotonda
e però
errore
che non so
se lo facciamo
anche noi
forse inconsciamente
sì
Mandeville dice
c'è il sopra
e c'è il sotto
se si gira
e si va
verso sud
si va
circolando
la rotondità
della terra
e del mare
perde sotto
il nostro paese
ed è qua
noi stiamo di sopra
nel nostro paese
ed è qua
e se andiamo a sud
andiamo sotto
ma non succede niente
se andiamo sotto
va tutto bene
lo stesso
e dice Mandeville
però
certo che sembra strano
perché gli ignoranti
ti dicono
ma se vai sotto
poi cadi
alla grossa
gente
notate
la grossa
gente
la gente
grossa
è la gente
che non è
sottile
è la gente
che non sa
ragionare
alla grossa
gente
pare che
non si possa
andare
sotto terra
e che se
cascaria
verso il cielo
de sotto
ma questo
non poteria
essere
altramente
che se noi
cascassimo
della terra
dove noi
siamo
sopra
dell'oro
in altre parole
non è che noi
siamo sopra
e loro sotto
ma dal punto di vista
loro siamo noi
che siamo sotto
noi non caschiamo
mica verso l'alto
e neanche loro
cascano verso l'alto
è un po' complicato
da spiegare
ma il concetto
è abbastanza
chiaro
a questo punto
siamo entrati
in un discorso
che non c'entra più
con la terra
piatta
perché come vedete
che la terra
è rotonda
non c'è proprio
la minima discussione
possibile
però siamo entrati
in un discorso
che c'entra
lo stesso
e anche se non c'entrasse
mi va di farvelo
e quindi ve lo faccio
comunque
dall'altra parte
del mondo
chi c'è
ci sta qualcuno
dall'altra parte
del mondo
agli antipodi
anzi
noi diciamo
gli antipodi
ma è un termine
che viene inventato
già nell'antichità
per indicare
non un luogo
ma per indicare
delle persone
gli antipodi
vuol dire
quelli che stanno
dall'altra parte
dei nostri piedi
noi abbiamo i piedi
ben piantati in terra
e vai giù
giù giù
sbuchi dall'altra parte
chi ci trovi
gli antipodi
che stanno
con i piedi per aria
naturalmente
esistono gli antipodi
nell'antichità
e nel medioevo
non c'era andato
nessuno
dall'altra parte
del mondo
quindi l'esperienza
non gli serviva
l'unico modo
per sapere
se ci poteva essere
qualcuno
dall'altra parte
del mondo
era di provare
a ragionarci su
e per secoli
nell'antichità
e nel medioevo
i dotti
si sono divertiti
da matti
a provare
a dimostrare
che qualcuno
ci poteva essere
oppure al contrario
no è impossibile
non ci può essere
nessuno
già gli antichi
quali erano
gli argomenti
di chi diceva
no non ci può essere
nessuno
dall'altra parte
del mondo
un argomento
lo abbiamo già sentito
era quello
della grossa gente
della gente
che non sa ragionare
non ci può essere
nessuno
dall'altra parte
del mondo
perché cascherebbero
giù
questo ragionamento
lo facevano già
gli ignoranti
nell'antichità
c'è una pagina
di Plinio
il Vecchio
nella storia naturale
che discute
di questo
primo secolo
Plinio
il Vecchio
dice
la terra è rotonda
lo sanno tutti
invece
che esistano
gli antipodi
cioè che ci sia
della gente
dall'altra parte
è una cosa
su cui c'è
un grosso conflitto
notate i termini
fra i letterati
e il volgo
perché il volgo
dice Plinio
che è un letterato
chiaramente
e ci tiene
a non essere uno
del volgo
il volgo
dice
se c'è qualcuno
dall'altra parte
perché non cadono giù
e Plinio dice
esattamente come dirà
Mandeville
1300 anni dopo
ma è ridicolo
pensare che se sono
dall'altra parte
cadano giù
come sarebbe ridicolo
pensare che cadiamo giù
noi
verso l'alto
nessuno cade giù
la legge di gravità
non l'avevano ancora
calcolata
ma che stiamo tutti
attaccati alla terra
questo l'avevano capito
perfettamente
con l'arrivo però
del cristianesimo
la discussione
sull'esistenza
di uomini
dall'altra parte
della terra
diventa più
serrata
perché ci sono
dei nuovi argomenti
da tenere presenti
e a quel punto
l'idea
che ci possa essere
della gente
dall'altra parte
del mondo
comincia a sembrare
più difficile
ci sono due ragioni
più di uno anzi
beh un ragionamento
scusate
adesso ho un po'
precorso i tempi
ma c'era un argomento
che usavano già
anche gli antichi
ve lo sbrigo in fretta
già gli antichi
dicevano
come è fatto il mondo
vabbè ai poli
fa un freddo cane
poi c'è una zona
temperata
dove abitiamo noi
per fortuna
e in mezzo
fa un caldo
da morire
all'equatore
c'è un caldo
torrido
siccome non c'era mai
stato nessuno
gli antichi
a un certo punto
si convincono
che all'equatore
fa un tale caldo
che non ci può
passare nessuno
in mezzo
fin qui
niente di male
ma poi
arrivano i cristiani
e i cristiani
dicono
tutti gli esseri
umani
discendono
da Adamo
e Adamo
è stato creato
in un posto
preciso
in Palestina
poi da lì
il genere umano
si è diffuso
ma come facevano
ad arrivare
dall'altra parte
del mondo
se in mezzo
c'è la zona
torrida
dove c'è un calore
bruciante
e nessuno
può passare
voi capite
noi dobbiamo sempre
cercare di immaginare
questa gente
che non ha modo
di saperlo
per esperienza
che deve provare
a ragionarci su
e ci ragiona su
in base agli elementi
che ha
tutti gli uomini
discendono
da Adamo
attraversare
l'equatore
è impossibile
perché lì si brucia
e quindi
non ci è andato
nessuno
dall'altra parte
e quindi
non ci può stare
nessuno
e poi c'è un secondo
motivo
il mondo
è coperto
in parte
di terra
emersa
e in parte
di acqua
io spero che mi stiate
sempre seguendo
lo so che sono
complicate queste cose
ma insomma
quest'anno vi è fatto
la scommessa
di raccontare
queste cose
complicate
ormai è troppo tardi
per cambiare
argomento
quindi voi
mi scuserete
lo stesso
ragionano
i filosofi antichi
e medievali
il mondo
è fatto
di terra
emersa
e di acqua
in che proporzione
per moltissimo tempo
hanno detto
poca terra
e tanta acqua
Aristotele
e voi sapete
che influenza
che ha avuto
Aristotele
per tutto il medioevo
Aristotele dice
uno a dieci
un decimo
di terra
emersa
tutto il resto
acqua
le terre
emerse
sono piccole
Cicerone
che non è
un superstizioso
medievale
Cicerone
a un certo punto
dice
sì
le terre
emerse
sono come
delle macchioline
sulla superficie
della terra
il resto
è tutta acqua
ma allora
anche ammettendo
che ci sia
qualche macchiolina
anche dall'altra parte
come si fa
a attraversare
tutto
quell'oceano
questo lo pensano
già gli antichi
è impossibile
poi arrivano i cristiani
i cristiani
leggono la Bibbia
nella Bibbia
c'è scritto
che Dio
ve lo ricordate tutti
prima creò le acque
e la terra
era interamente
ricoperta
dalle acque
poi Dio
fece ritirare
le acque
per far venire fuori
la terra
emersa
però insomma
signori
se fece ritirare
le acque
comunque
è evidente
che il grosso
è coperto di acque
e che la terra
emersa
è piccolissima
per tutti questi motivi
i filosofi antichi
e i teologi medievali
dicono
non lo sappiamo
con certezza
ma secondo me
dall'altra parte del mondo
non c'è niente
e poi arriva
Cristoforo Colombo
e con lui
ci ricolleghiamo
al nostro argomento
di partenza
e ci arriviamo
anche a concludere
qual è il vero problema
per Colombo
l'abbiamo visto
che la terra è rotonda
lo sanno tutti
non ha bisogno
di spiegare a nessuno
che la terra è rotonda
Colombo
arriva
e dice
ecco
cosa dice Colombo
alla regina Isabella
cos'è che si è messo in testa
lui
proviamo a ricordarci
il contesto
quella è un'epoca
fine 400
in cui si fanno
un sacco di soldi
col commercio
delle spezie
ma davvero
un sacco di soldi
ci si fa il bilancio
di uno stato
col commercio
delle spezie
e le spezie
vengono in Oriente
per secoli
si andava a prenderle
in Oriente
le andavano a prendere
i mercanti arabi
poi le portavano
ad orso di cammello
fino all'Egitto
e lì
ci si imbarcava
si attraversava
il Mediterraneo
pieno di pirati
e si arrivava
finalmente a Venezia
o a Genova
con queste spezie
il costo
era terrificante
prima di Colombo
ma non tanto tempo
prima
i portoghesi
hanno scoperto
che invece di infognarsi
nel Mediterraneo
e aspettare
la carovana
del Mar Rosso
si può fare
con la nave
il giro
dell'Africa
fai il giro
doppi il capo
di buona speranza
e arrivi
in India
e ci metti
meno tempo
e quindi
sul carico
di spezie
ci fai un profitto
molto maggiore
e i portoghesi
si arricchiscono
Colombo
va dalla regina
di Spagna
e le dice
io ho un'idea
che ci farà
guadagnare
un sacco di soldi
perché ho pensato
una rotta
molto più breve
per arrivare
in Oriente
dice Colombo
siccome la terra
è rotonda
se uno parte
dalla Spagna
verso Occidente
fa tutto
il giro
e arriva
in Oriente
e così
freghiamo
i portoghesi
allora
non è vero
niente
della storia
della commissione
di Salamanca
i dotti
vediamo
quello che noi
sappiamo
è che
Colombo
presenta
questo progetto
alla regina
con tutti i calcoli
quanto tempo ci vuole
quanto è lunga
la strada
e la regina
siccome si tratta
di spendere
parecchi soldi
fa quello
che probabilmente
si farebbe anche oggi
nomina una commissione
una commissione
di specialisti
che devono
valutare
il progetto
di Colombo
non sono
i dotti
dell'università
di Salamanca
è una commissione
di esperti
che si riunisce
varie volte
dopo qualche mese
danno un primo parere
negativo
ma siccome Colombo
è molto raccomandato
e ha molti amici influenti
alla commissione
dicono
un supplemento
di indagine
pensateci ancora un po'
ci pensano parecchi anni
si riuniscono
qualche volta
a Salamanca
a Cordova
dove c'è la corte
che si sposta
cosa dice
la commissione
dice
questo progetto
di Colombo
è molto ardito
ci sarebbero
dei problemi
ovviamente
non c'è più bisogno
che ve lo dica
che nessuno
nella commissione
si alza per dire
che la terra è piatta
perché
nella commissione
dicono
sì
lui vuole andare di là
ma questo fatto
della zona torrida
però poi è vero
che non siamo proprio sicuri
che sia così torrida
e poi magari
stando solo
pazienza
questo lasciamo perdere
il vero problema
è la commissione
che dice
Colombo
ci ha dato
certe misure
secondo lui
il viaggio
dura tanto
e si può fare
ma noi
che abbiamo letto
gli scienziati
greci
abbiamo letto
Eratostene
che ha calcolato
la circonferenza
della terra
a noi
i calcoli di Colombo
non ci torna mica
tanto
secondo noi
non ci arriva
è molto più lungo
il viaggio
di quello che dice
Colombo
perciò noi
consigliamo
di non spendere soldi
per questa roba
il dramma
col senno di poi
è che avevano ragione
loro
Colombo
aveva completamente
sbagliato
i calcoli
non è ancora chiaro
quanto in mala fede
e quanto perché
ci credeva così tanto
ma è stato ricostruito
il modo in cui
Colombo
ha fatto i suoi calcoli
che distanza c'è
dalla Spagna
all'estremo oriente
facendo il giro
da occidente
Colombo
ha fatto di tutto
ha letto Marco Polo
ha provato a calcolare
quanto è grande
la Cina
secondo Marco Polo
e si è tenuto largo
perché se la Cina
è molto grande
si spinge molto in là
e quindi ci si arriva
prima per mare
Colombo
ha considerato
tutti i calcoli
che esistevano
sulla circonferenza
della terra
e ha preso
il più basso
e l'ha dato
per buono
poi ha barato
sulle misure
c'erano delle misure
espresse in miglia marittime
lui ha fatto finta
che fossero miglia terrestre
che sono più corte
insomma alla fine
Colombo presenta
un calcolo
in cui dice
la distanza
dalle Canarie
già perché anziché
calcolare dalla Spagna
già che c'è
calcola dalle Canarie
che sono già un po' più in là
risparmia
dice Colombo
la distanza
dalle Canarie
all'estremo oriente
sono
4.500 km
lui si esprime
in miglia
ma insomma
comunque
corrisponde a questo
4.500 km
sapete quant'è davvero
la distanza
dalle Canarie
all'estremo oriente
tenetevi forte
22.000 km
in altre parole
Colombo parte
e normalmente
dovrebbero morire
tutti di sete
dopo un mese
nel pieno dell'oceano
è salvato dal fatto
che va a sbattere
contro l'America
che nessuno
sapeva che c'era
ed essendo lì
a metà strada
Colombo
arriva a toccare
terra
e quindi alla fine
ha avuto ragione
lui evidentemente
e infatti
la principale cosa
che gli scienziati
del Cinquecento
imparano
dalla scoperta
dell'America
è
ci eravamo sbagliati
credevamo
che le terre emerse
fossero poche
e che l'insieme
del globo
fosse coperto
d'acqua
invece non è vero
abbiamo scoperto
cito da un trattato
cinquecentesco
che non c'è
quella gran quantità
d'acqua
che si credeva
bene ma se le cose
sono andate così
e io ormai
ho solo più cinque minuti
ma vediamo di dire
ancora qualcosa
rapidamente
com'è che noi
abbiamo invece
tutti visto i quadri
o le vignette di Colombo
con i dotti di Salamanca
il mappamondo
com'è che abbiamo
in testa questa idea
dei dotti di Salamanca
che ignorantissimi
sostengono
che la terra è piatta
e quindi Colombo
non ce la può fare
chi l'ha inventata
questa frottola
qui si sa
il colpevole
o meglio
sì
c'è anche un nome
e cognome
che adesso vi farò
ma diciamo
più in generale
è colpa degli americani
i quali americani
devono per forza
credere
che Colombo
ovviamente
ha cambiato
la storia del mondo
e quindi Colombo
è un grande eroe
che ha combattuto
contro l'ignoranza
e la superstizione
questa immagine
di Colombo
come grande eroe
che mette fine
ormai sono tre sere
che lo ripeto
alle tenebre del medioevo
e porta la luce
della conoscenza
agli americani
importa in modo particolare
all'inizio dell'ottocento
c'è uno scrittore americano
che si chiama
Washington Irving
molto famoso in America
meno da noi
che scrive un libro
che si intitola proprio
La vita e i viaggi
di Cristoforo Colombo
Washington Irving
sa
che ci sono stati
dei dotti
a Salamanca
che hanno criticato Colombo
e che non volevano
dargli soldi
non sa nient'altro
descrive
questa scena
meravigliosa
sono pagine
e pagine
straordinarie
con tutta
questa coalizione
di ignoranti
che cerca
di fermare
il progresso
della verità
e quindi
tira in ballo
gli antipodi
e la tenda
della Bibbia
e il profeta
Isaia
come se
i dotti
del Quattrocento
fossero ancora fermi
come mille anni prima
a discutere
di quelle cose lì
e crea questa immagine
meravigliosa
il libro
in America
lo leggono tutti
questa immagine
di Colombo
e dei dotti
di Salamanca
si imprime
per sempre
nella memoria collettiva
in America
la si ritrova
tuttora
nei libri di scuola
e del resto
il Campidoglio
di Washington
ha delle porte
di bronzo
Columbus Doors
dove è proprio
immortalato
nel bronzo
Colombo
che eroicamente
discute
con i dotti
di Salamanca
e quindi
questa immagine
si radica
per sempre
Colombo
rappresenta
la modernità
illuminata
contro
la superstizione
e l'ignoranza
del passato
chiudiamo
ma diciamo ancora
una cosettina
allora lo sapevano
tutti che la terra
è rotonda
d'accordo
ma allora
chi ha scritto
questa frase
ecco
provate a indovinare
quando è stata scritta
questa dimostrazione
sentite
gli esseri umani
hanno bisogno
di una superficie
su cui vivere
che in genere
deve essere piatta
il creatore
è onnisciente
quindi lo sa benissimo
che noi abbiamo bisogno
di una superficie
piatta
per vivere
il creatore
è infinitamente
saggio
e quindi
naturalmente
è adatto
alle sue creature
tutto ciò
di cui hanno bisogno
sottointeso
una superficie piatta
su cui vivere
questa è una prova
teologica
che la terra
non è
una sfera
io sono abbastanza sicuro
che se avessi cominciato
la lezione
leggendogli questo brano
e dicendo
che era di uno
dei dotti di Salamanca
probabilmente
sarebbe andato bene
a tutti
questo brano
è di un signore
americano
dell'ottocento
che si chiama
William Carpenter
che nel 1885
ha pubblicato
a Baltimora
a sue spese
va detto
a onore
dell'editoria americana
un libro
intitolato
le cento prove
che la terra
non è una sfera
in altre parole
è la prima volta
nella storia
che viene scritto
un libro
per dimostrare
che la terra
è piatta
e siamo in America
alla fine del 1800
queste cento prove
sono fantastiche
cercatelo in internet
c'è tutto
e leggetevelo
la prima prova
è questa
se uno sale
con un pallone
e guarda giù
si vede benissimo
che è piatta
allora appunto
come dire
coda
all'ultimissima cosa
William Carpenter
non è solo
alla fine dell'ottocento
nasce in America
la società
della terra piatta
che esiste ancora
andate a cercare
c'è il sito internet
Flat Earth Society
sono alcune migliaia
di persone
convinte
che la terra
è piatta
e che ci fanno
credere
che è rotonda
perché ci fanno
credere
tutto quello
che vogliono
ci hanno fatto
credere
che siamo andati
sulla luna
è tutta una montatura
in altre parole
oggi
forse
per la prima volta
esiste gente
che crede davvero
che la terra
è piatta
e
lo crede
perché è convinta
che tutto
quello
che ci dicono
è un inganno
che qualunque
cosa ci dicono
bisogna pensare
che è falsa
perché c'è la congiura
per ingannarci
allora io
mentre pensavo
a queste cose
mi sono detto
sembra quasi
quello che io ho fatto
in queste sere
di dire
ecco
io spero
di non aver fatto
questo in queste sere
io non ho detto
qualunque cosa
vi dicono
state attenti
perché è falsa
però spero
di avervi detto
qualunque cosa
ci dicono
non è che ci dobbiamo
credere solo
perché ce l'hanno detta
e se è una cosa
a cui teniamo
e a cui abbiamo voglia
di credere
sul serio
ecco
non basta
che ce l'hanno detta
e che l'abbiamo letta
ma nei limiti
delle nostre possibilità
bisogna
cercare
di andare
a controllare
grazie
e naturalmente
all'anno prossimo
grazie